ucrania da un paso importante para
acercarse a la unión europea la
presidenta de la comisión europea ursula
von der leyen anunció que recomienda
otorgar a ucrania el estatus de
candidato a la adhesión es un objetivo
que quien lleva buscando desde 2014
tenemos un mensaje claro y es si ucrania
merece una perspectiva europea
y es si ucrania debe ser bienvenida como
país candidatos
y esto es en el entendimiento de que se
ha hecho un buen trabajo pero también
queda un trabajo importante por hacer
todo el proceso se basa en el mérito es
mérito es el asunto será ahora tratado
por los 27 países de la unión europea en
la cumbre que comenzará el 23 de junio y
cualquier decisión deberá ser unánime
pero algunos miembros como países bajos
dinamarca y bélgica han expresado sus
reservas sobre la candidatura de kiev es
el primer paso en un proceso que podría
llevar años si estamos dispuestos a
reconocer a ucrania como país candidato
pero se lo dijimos a todos con la misma
franqueza este proceso llevará tiempo
habrá condiciones habrá una hoja de ruta
que será fijada por la comisión para ser
cumplida y así ustedes no serán miembros
de la unión europea mañana como parte de
ese proceso que tendrá que cumplir los
criterios de adhesión en su totalidad lo
que incluye llevar a cabo las reformas
necesarias para adecuar sus
instituciones y leyes a las de la unión
europea eso significa tener una
democracia estable una economía de
mercado respetar los derechos humanos y
la igual de género proteger a las
minorías la comisión europea se dijo
también favorable a un estatuto de
candidato a la unión europea para
moldavia pero anunció que georgia tiene
que cumplir condiciones antes de
obtenerlo